hi i'm clara amfo and this is my
glamifesto for
life
[Music]
my daily mantra is this too shall pass
which is potentially quite cliche but
i've really learned that on a really
good day
and on a really bad day equally this too
shall pass you know
um and i think with that i really try
and savor my good days because i know
that they may not last forever
my instant mood booster is dancing
around my kitchen
and singing around my kitchen i've
definitely found
especially during lockdown hashtag
this time i'm calling the panna cotta
that's my favorite variant of the
pandemic
in my friendships the thing that i value
the most
is honesty consistency
and vulnerability actually when the
panna cotta
is over there are so many things i can't
wait for i can't wait to go
raven again i miss going to the club i
really miss going to cinema that was
always one of my favorite
sunday rituals and i want to travel i
love to travel
i feel glam where my eyebrows are
don't i'll happily wear no makeup as my
eyebrows are on and i've actually got
and i've got a lip gloss on
and i'm moisturized i'm good what is the
quirkiest thing i do in the name of
wellness i think i just try and big
myself up out loud
there's a show that i'm obsessed with
and called insecure which stars the
incredible issa rae
there's bits where she's talking to
herself in the mirror and she raps to
herself
i'm not quite there with the wrapping
yet but you know she'll be like you're
bad
the only person that can truly cheerlead
you
in the best possible way outside of your
friends and family
is you the thing that makes me most
proud of my heritage
is our warmth when i say our i'm talking
about ghanaian people i am from
ghana um and the ghanaian mantra
and motto is a kwaba which means you're
welcome
even my welcome mat at my door it has
acquired a cuava aquaba written
three times i think my biggest passion
is the pursuit of happiness and i'm
passionate about living a life that i
enjoy who could i not
live without i'll tell you what that's a
really interesting question
for a few reasons because i think i've
learned
through losing somebody very close to me
even though it's painful do learn you do
learn to
live live without people because they
never really leave you and i mean on a
completely um
superficial level couldn't live without
a good
slice of red velvet cake at least
at least once a month the best way to
clap back
against misogyny is is twofold really
it's to carry on doing what i'm doing
without giving up
i look forward to the day where i don't
have to be asked this question i look
forward today
when we don't have to protest for like
basic things even things like you know
like
the whole issue around period poverty
the biggest
inspiration in my life i would say
is my mum and it's interesting because
she has
she has grown into that for me because
she's always been inspirational
i just didn't realize how much so until
i became an alleged adult myself
i have really learned to deal with
failure by truly understanding and truly
believing the phrase what's meant for
you
won't pass you by i've definitely
suffered from imposter syndrome and it's
something that i'm really proud to say
that i've i'd say i've beaten
about 80 of the way i would always
always always say
do it for the work not for the perks
always always always
in five years from now i want to be
producing tv shows
i want to know how to be able to cook a
great meal
without giving any of my friends food
policy
my legacy i think purse on a personal
level
i would want my legacy to be um
she was a good friend an honest friend a
loyal friend
sister daughter colleague
and she was a laugh um and on a
professional level
um she did great work
that kept me company and made me think
and made me smile
this has been my glamifesto for life and
thank you for having me